elon musk
mentioned in his usual humorous way on
twitter
that he wants to launch the texas
institute of technology and science
tits
some people thought this was sexist
because of the acronym tits
uh so first of all i understand their
viewpoint uh but i also think there
needs to be a place for humor on the
internet
even from ceo so on this podcast i've
gotten a chance to talk to quite a few
ceos
and what i love to see is authenticity
and humor is often a sign of
authenticity the
the quirkiness that you mentioned is
such a beautiful characteristic of
professors and faculty and great
universities is also beautiful to see as
ceos especially founding ceo so
anyway
uh the deeper
point he was making is showing an
excitement for the university as a place
for big ideas in
science technology engineering so to me
if there's some kind of way if there is
a serious thought that he had behind
this tweet
not to analyze elon musk's twitter like
it's shakespeare but if there's a
serious thought
i would love to see him supporting
the the flourishing of austin as a place
for science technology
for these kinds of intellectual
developments that uh
that that we're talking about like make
um
make a place for free inquiry
civil disagreements
coupled with
great education
and conversations about artificial
intelligence about technology about
engineering so i'm actually gonna uh
i hope there's a serious idea behind
that tweet and i'm gonna i'm gonna chat
with him about it i do too i do too i uh
most of the
uh
biggest
uh
storms and teacups of my academic career
have been
caused by bad jokes that i've made
these days if you want to make
bad jokes being a billionaire is a great
idea uh
i'm not here to defend elon's uh
twitter style or sense of humor
he's not going to be remembered for his
tweets i think uh he's going to be
remembered for the astonishing
companies that he's built and his his
contributions
in a whole range of fields
from spacex to tesla
and solar energy and i very much hope
that we can
interest elon in this project we need
not only elon but a whole range of uh
his peers
because
this takes
resources universities are not cheap
things to run especially
if as i hope we can make as much of
uh
the the tuition
uh covered by scholarships and bursaries
we we want to attract the best
intellectual talent to this institution
the best intellectual talent is somewhat
randomly distributed through society and
some of it is in the bottom quintile of
the income distribution and that makes
it hard to get to elite education so
this will take resources
the last generation of
super wealthy plutocrats the generation
of the gilded age of the late 19th
century did a pretty good job of
founding universities
chicago wouldn't exist
but for the money of that era
and so my message to not only to elon
but to all of
the peers all of those people who made
their billions
out of technology over the last couple
of decades is
this is your time i mean and this is
your opportunity to create something new
i can't really understand why
the wealthy of our time are content to
hand their money i mean think of the
vast sums mike bloomberg recently gave
to johns hopkins to his established
institutions
when
on close inspection those institutions
don't seem to spend the money terribly
well
and in fact one of the mysteries of our
time is the lack of due diligence that
hard-nosed billionaires seem to do when
it comes to philanthropy
so
i think there's an opportunity here for
this generation of very talented wealthy
people to
to do what their their counterparts did
in the late 19th and early 20th century
and and create some new institutions
and they don't need to put their names
on the buildings they just need to do
what what the founders of
of chicago university of chicago did to
create something new that will that will
endure
yeah uh mit is launching a college of
computing and um
steven schwartzman is
given quite a large sum of money i think
in total a billion dollars
and
as somebody who loves computing and
somebody who loves mit i want some
accountability
uh for mit becoming a better institution
and this is once again why i'm excited
about university of austin because it
serves as a beacon look you can create
something new
and this is what the great institutions
of the future should look like
and steve schwartzman
uh is also an innovator the idea of
creating a college
on the tsinghua campus
and creating a kind of roads program for
students from the western world to come
study in china was was steve's idea and
and i was somewhat involved did some
visiting professing there
it taught me that you can create
something new
uh in that area of graduate education
and quite quickly attract really strong
applicants
because the people who finish their four
years at harvard or stanford know
that they don't know a lot
and i
having taught a lot of people
in that group know
how intellectually dissatisfied they
often are at the end of four years
i mean they may have beautifully gained
the system to graduate sumo magna [ __ ]
laude but they kind of know
they they'll confess it after a drink or
two they know that they gained the
system and that intellectually it wasn't
the fulfilling experience they wanted
and they also know that an mba from a
comparable institution would not be a
massive intellectual step forward so i
think what we want to say uh is here's
something really novel exciting that
will
be intellectually very challenging i i
do think the university of austin has to
be difficult
yeah um i'd like it to feel a little bit
like surviving navy seal training to
come through this program because it
will be intellectually demanding
and that i think should be a magnet so
yeah steve if you're listening uh please
join elon in in supporting this and and
and
peter thiel if you're listening i know
how skeptical you are about the idea of
creating a new university because
heaven knows peter and i have been
discussing this idea for years and he's
always said well no we thought about
this and it just isn't going to work but
i
really think we've got a we got a
responsibility to to do this well
steve's been on this podcast before
we've uh spoken a few times so i'll send
this to him i hope he does actually get
behind it as well so i'm i'm super
excited by
the ideas that we've been talking about
that this uh effort represents and
what ripple effect it has on the rest of
society so thank you that was a time
beautifully spent and i'm really
grateful for the
the fortune
of
getting a chance to talk to you at this
moment in history because i've been a
big fan of your work and the reason i
wanted to talk to you today is
about all the excellent books you've
written about various aspects of history
through money war
power pandemics all of that but i'm glad
that
this we got a chance to talk about this
which is not looking at history it's
looking at the future
this is a beautiful little
fortuitous
moment i appreciate you talking about it
you